the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones anna
song of ice and fire video in this video
i want to do something a little
different i will go over something that
i still see a lot of fans getting wrong
now as you all know before jaime
lannister lost his sword hand he was
considered as one of the greatest
swordsmen in the realm in fact there are
some fans who believe jaime would have
defeated anyone in a sword fight then
there are also other fans who think
jaime lannister would have lost when he
faced off against ned stark in the first
season if it would have been a fair
fight exactly how good jaime was is
something fans have been debating about
for well over a decade many fans wonder
if there is anyone who could have
defeated jaime when he was at his best
well we may never know for sure but
jaime lannister did reveal something
very interesting when he was fighting
lady berean now we don't actually learn
about this information in the show we
find this out when jaime is fighting
brienne in the books because during the
scene we are inside jaime's head this
was when he revealed exactly which
characters were stronger than him there
are 8 different characters on this list
some of them were still alive and some
of them are dead now before i go any
further how many of you actually know
who all of them are i want you to stop
the video right here if you have to then
go down into the comments and name all
of the characters who jaime said were
stronger than him i want to see how many
of you actually get this right alright
now let me show you what he said when
him and brianne were sword fighting
jaime thinks to himself she is stronger
than i am the realization chilled him
robert had been stronger than him to be
sure the white bull gerald hightower as
well in his heyday and sir arthur dane
among the living great john umber was
stronger strong bore of cray-call most
likely and both cleganes for a certainty
the mountain's strength was like nothing
human it did not matter as long as jaime
had his speed and skill he could beat
them all but this was a woman a huge cow
of a woman to be sure but even so by
right she should be the one wearing down
instead she forced him back into the
brook again shouting yield throw down
the sword as you can see these are the
eight characters who jaime said were
stronger than him but he still thought
he could have beat all of them so long
as he had his speed and skill which she
did not have against buryin
not only were his hands bound at the
wrist but he had been malnourished as
well now one thing we have to remember
is this was when jaime still had his
sword hand and before he lost that sword
hand we all know jaime had a massive ego
so there may have been other characters
who were better than him that he did not
want to admit to himself but then again
who knows maybe he was right on the
money maybe he would have defeated all
of these men and women on his best day
all we can do is guess
now there was no mention of barristan
selmy on the list a character who many
fans believe is the greatest swordsman
ever there are also other characters who
may have been stronger than jaime that
he simply did not know like call drogo
or belwas either way jaime basically
considered himself to be the greatest
swordsman in westeros even if some were
stronger than him
now how many of you actually remembered
each of those names he thought about how
many of you actually believe him do you
really think jaime would have defeated
the hound the mountain and even sir
arthur dane i'm not so sure about that
myself i think sir arthur dayne would
have defeated jaime
now at the beginning of a game of
thrones jaime most likely was the
greatest swordsman in westeros since sir
arthur dain was dead and barest and
selmy was very old but maybe you feel
some other way let me know what you
think down below
this has always been one of my favorite
debates in the game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire fandom so i am very
interested in seeing what all of you
have to say about this one as always i
want to thank everyone for stopping by
and watching the video i hope all of you
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you